bueno el terremoto es grande por
supuesto dejan momentos más de seis mil
personas muertas pero Comparado con la
actividad sísmica de cualquier zona del
Pacífico hay otros más grandes incluso
de mayor energía verdad Por qué este
terremoto ha destruido tanto bueno
efectivamente no es un terremoto grande
pero en un terremoto enorme no es muy
grande los mayores daños se producen por
el digamos una deficiencia la tipología
constructiva es decir cómo están
construidas las casas como aquí se ha
comentado en Siria ha sufrido una guerra
civil y una guerra que está impidiendo
pues incluso
renovar los edificios Y esa es la
consecuencia fundamental es decir hay
malos edificios mal construidos ya
estamos viendo que son casas que se han
hundido totalmente y claro
automáticamente
5.000 casas pensando 10 personas por
casa que son bloques de casa está
hablando Ya directamente de 5.000 50.000
muertos en un momento determinado No
ahora usted ha dicho que no estamos
hablando de una placa inestable no
podría aclararnos como experto que
ocurre a nivel de las placas tectónicas
en estos sucesos
bien la tierra la parte donde nosotros
estamos pisando que la corteza Aunque
nosotros nos parezca dura es lo más la
parte más frágil de la tierra en este
caso cuando hay una serie de fuerzas que
mueven que están generadas el interior
de la tierra pues estas placas esta
corteza se rompen diferentes zonas y
aquí hay una zona que se llama la placa
de anatolia que se mueve en dirección
oeste en el norte tiene una gran falla
que es la falla de anatolia que ha sido
la causante de varias veces la
destrucción de las ciudades de Estambul
cuando se llama incluso Constantinopla
en el sur está esta falla generan
grandes terremotos porque son grandes
zonas de fricción evidentemente siempre
se van a volver a repetir se sabe que
hay terremotos hablan de terremoto más
grande del año de 1930 pero el año 70
también hubo en la zona norte también
hubo y es un problema también pues de la
autoridad velar por sabiendo que haber
terremoto por la seguridad de la de la
población pero es un problema también
económico y importante que ocurre en
todo el mundo Ahora hay avisos sobre un
eventual gran terremoto no el Big Bang
en los próximos años existe un riesgo
real para que esto suceda
hay un terremoto digamos en Turquía la
falla norte de la actualidad
nos falta un trozo por romper que el que
está cerca de Estambul y por tanto si es
muy probable que los próximos años en el
norte vuelva a haber un terremoto que
afecte directamente a la capital lo que
esperamos siempre es que la capital esté
mejor construido que en el sur ocurre lo
mismo por ejemplo en la zona mexicana
que ahí lo que llamamos el Gap de
Guerrero que es una zona donde también
se espera que ocurra un terremoto y así
sucesivamente zonas donde sabemos que se
repiten los terremotos y sabremos que en
un momento terminado pueden ocurrir
estos grandes terremotos de nuevo
También estamos esperando uno en San
Francisco por ejemplo qué podemos vender
para el futuro Jesús es necesario
invertir y también educar a las
poblaciones en materia de terremotos
verdad
sobre todo primero invertir es decir que
la autoridad sean capaces de bueno ver
cual el edificio se construye Hay un
problema de autoconstrucción Hay un
problema de corrupción es decir cuando
no se pone la cantidad de hormigón o
cuando no se sigue las normas Turquía
oficialmente tiene una de las normas y
más resistentes más importantes del
mundo lo que estamos viendo aquí ahora
que nos está siguiendo luego con
respecto a la población ocurre lo mismo
es decir cómo actuar cuando ocurre un
terremoto o incluso ver dónde estamos
viviendo no que eso es algo importante
evidentemente no podemos elegir cuando
nuestra situación económica no lo
permite pero si bien es cierto que luego
en un momento determinado Pues aquí hace
falta la voluntad también de la
cooperación internacional estamos viendo
pues por ejemplo pues la guerras como se
solicita Rusia que ayude como Irán
incluso la ayuda están llegando en
función de la afinidad de políticas y
esto es realmente triste porque cuando
más pase decir estamos hablando Ya de 48
horas prácticamente
la probabilidad de encontrar
sobrevivientes es mucho menor y
la unidad de rescate están llegando a
cuentagotas la ayuda por tanto todos los
que las personas que están sepultadas
muy probablemente Dentro de poco pues
perecerán entonces hablaremos de decenas
de miles de Muertos o sea no sería
extrañar que el balance final estuviera
entre 30 y 50.000 muertos